product not yet rated
hi my name is Jim Boone senior producer
on scene Troodon FL we're excited to
show you the new city of new Hades and
to show you the gameplay with them let's
get started for the first time ever
players now the chance to play as Johnny
Gat the most badass of all the Saints
and you're just going to acquaint
himself with some of the demons in Hell
gat style
one of the things we've always had a lot
of fun with and seen to our games as
introducing new weapons and this one
here is the Exodus 10 this is the locust
plague in a gun
and now we're going to show you one of
the fan favorites from pax this is the
armchair again this is based off of one
of the seven deadly sins and thus it's
the slop gun
now we're going to introduce a new
diversion called R ambulance the goal
here is to run over as many husks as you
possibly can and you're probably
wondering why we have ambulances and
health because you wouldn't want to help
anyone in health but in this case it's a
ram Beulah
now that GATS Fitness regulates it's
time for him to explore a new section of
health and now we're going to show off
our new key feature flight and here
we're going to show it a little bit more
closely in the hell blazing activity for
those familiar with blazing from seat
row 4 this is very similar except with
flight the goal for gas is to go through
the different way points as quickly as
he can
this particular area that is going
through is the shantytown it's a lot of
very claustrophobic sorts of areas very
rundown this is where the poor bastards
the lost souls and hospice of hell live
white orbs will give them wing flaps
which guy uses to get quick bursts of
speed and the green orbs will give him
stamina
god is good
in Asheville central for you have bronze
silver and gold levels of completion
you'll be able to use respect and wages
to be able to buy upgrades for yourself
as well as to be able to upgrade various
weapons and different abilities very
going to show you what if gasps new
ability is you able to summon imps these
little guys will run up and attack the
enemies the worm hammer is powerful in
its own right it has a smite ability
which brings the lightning from the sky
down in your enemies
seed has a number of Defense's at its
disposal in this case the spire
so cats gonna take it out with a new
ability this one is called warship aura
yeah it's going to quickly take care of
the enemy and ultimately disable the
spire by ripping the heart out